La cousine de Valentine, elle ne peut pas être immortelle. Puisqu’elle est morte.
Y a de la place dans le congel, on n’a qu’à la mettre là dedans en attendant.
C’est quoi ça ?
Attend mais c’est une météorite ?
Tu fais quoi avec un œuf de Yoni toi ?
Un quoi ?
Franchement, je ne sais pas si je vais tenir une semaine de plus avec vous tous ici.
Ça commence à faire beaucoup.
Bon alors c’est simple, vous fixez le point là.
Bon là c’est un miroir je sais,
c’est pas une vitre sans tain, dans loft story ils avaient ça, mais c’est pas la même prod, c’est pas les mêmes moyens mais ça imite assez bien.
Et puis, vous lâchez ce que vous avez sur le coeur, vous videz votre sac,
comme si vous étiez chez le psy
ou comme si vous parliez à votre communauté Twitter.
Et puis vraiment, allez y. Parce que je trouve qu’on a une ambiance de merde là
et puis ça va être un bon moyen de règler tout ça.
Un Créatif, tu viens, tu commences.
Nan mais c’est débile son truc, j’vais pas parler à une vitre quand même…
Vous vous êtes sûrement déjà demandé comment on pourrait améliorer le français pour qu’il soit plus efficace,
histoire que l’on communique plus facilement et avec moins d'ambiguïtés.
Et comme on vit dans une époque formidable,
avec l’outil informatique pour nous assister
avec une science qui n’a jamais été aussi dynamique,
on devrait théoriquement pouvoir pimper nos langues afin qu’elles soient plus optimales pour communiquer.
Si seulement c’était si simple…
Cette problématique, elle est tout sauf nouvelle.
Le philosophe Francis Bacon théorise déjà la langue universelle optimale en 1605,
en imaginant un système d’écriture où chaque symbole correspond à un seul radical,
une seule notion ou un seul concept, afin que chacun puisse lire et comprendre un texte sans en parler la langue.
Alors évidemment, c’est vain puisque c’est dissocier la langue de sa grammaire
et comme toutes les langues ne mettent pas les mots dans le même ordre, par exemple,
peu de chance que tout le monde s’y retrouve.
D’autres après lui se pencheront sur le problème,
que ce soit Leibniz, Comenius, Wilkins, Tolstoï ou même Descartes.
Déjà au 17e siècle, ce dernier résume bien l’idée que les gens se font encore aujourd’hui de l’optimalité de la langue.
Une langue optimale est internationale,
à la grammaire simple et que l’on peut apprendre en quelques heures,
ne possède ni exceptions ni irrégularités.
Ces principes sont à la base des langues construites les plus connues,
comme le volapük qui fut le premier à rencontrer un succès international,
et l’espéranto ensuite qui le remplaça.
Mais entre 1880 et la seconde guerre mondiale, ce sont plus de 200 langues répondant à ces critères qui seront créées,
la plupart d’entre elles par des européens,
le lexique optimal semble tendre alors pour beaucoup du côté des racines européennes.
Plutôt que d’améliorer une langue déjà existante, on pourrait donc créer une langue de toute pièce qui réponde à des exigences d’optimalité,
afin de transmettre le plus rapidement possible des informations entre êtres humains
mais aussi à destination d’une machine ou d’un ordinateur.
Ou pour reprendre les arguments de beaucoup de créateurs de ces langues,
apporter la paix dans le monde.
Bah ouais, autant être ambitieux un petit peu.
Ils manquent tous d’ambition quand même,
je ne sais pas comment ils font pour s’assumer en tant qu’individu.
Nan mais Un Créatif,
il a un de ces melons.
C’est incroyable.
Il fait des grands discours inspirants, à la cool et machin.
Mais en fait, tout le monde sait que c’est un flemmard.
Florence, par exemple. Est-ce qu’elle entreprendrait elle-même
de sortir les poubelles ou faire la vaisselle par exemple ?
Est-ce qu’elle bousculerait le planning ?
Est-ce qu’elle ferait preuve d’initiative ?
Non, parce que pour elle, y a que les règles.
Les règles, les règles, les règles.
Pour moi, les règles sont faites pour être bousculées, pour être affranchies.
Justement, Monté, avec ce truc de confessionnal, ça j’aime bien,
c’est disruptif, c’est bien.
Ils ne savent pas ce qui les attend.
Ça promet d’être marrant.
Moi ça va… à part quelques problèmes,
je trouve qu’on communique pas trop mal.
La première langue construite à viser l’optimalité est certainement le Loglan,
conçue en 1955 par James Cooke Brown, puisqu’elle visait un but scientifique dans la recherche linguistique.
Le Loglan, dont le nom est composé de Logic et Language, visait plusieurs buts.
Être purement basée sur la logique tout d’abord, mais également être neutre culturellement,
être la plus minimaliste grammaticalement pour être facilement apprise,
être la plus élaborée possible pour néanmoins permettre des raisonnements complexes,
et finalement être dénuée d’ambiguités.
Elle visait alors à valider l’hypothèse Sapir-Whorf dans sa version forte,
selon laquelle la langue structure notre pensée.
Il suffirait alors de voir si une langue purement basée sur la logique pourrait amener ses locuteurs à penser plus logiquement.
Le Loglan dans le principe rappelle le langage mathématique et logique qu’ont tenté de créer Frege, Russell et Carnap.
Un énoncé simple est transformé en énoncé logique.
Prenons par exemple la phrase “tous les chiens sont bleus”,
on pourra le noter ainsi : “pour tout x où x est un chien, x est bleu”
Le Loglan s’inspire de cette notation mathématique et traduit cet énoncé ainsi :
radaku da kangu u da blanu,
où da équivaut à l’inconnue que l’on définit,
kangu et blanu aux arguments à savoir “chien” et “bleu”,
ra- à “tout”, -ku à “celui-ci”, u à “si, alors”.
L’histoire du Loglan finira mal.
James Cooke Brown espère de l’argent de son université pour sa création mais celle-ci lui refuse.
L’homme, qui est alors insulté dans son honneur, veut conserver un contrôle strict sur le Loglan, afin notamment d’en exploiter d’éventuels droits d’auteurs.
Bien que cela puisse sembler incroyable, Brown considérait avoir un droit de propriété sur le lexique,
c’est-à-dire sur chaque mot du loglan.
Attendez, on peut déposer une langue et demander du droit d’auteur ?
OH !
Quoi ?
Bon bah ouais alors, est-ce qu’on peut déposer une langue, est-ce qu’on peut copyrighter des mots ? Est-ce qu’on peut… propriété intellectuelle, langue, tout ça ?
T’as bien des trucs à dire là-dessus ?
Non, tu me poses une colle là en fait.
J’en sais rien du tout.
Nan mais tu te renseignes, et puis tu…
Nan, nan, nan. Mais c’est pas parce que tu fais du droit que tu connais tout en fait.
Tu ne peux pas être spécialiste de la question sur toutes les choses qui existent.
- D’accord, donc tu ne vas pas me répondre.
- Bah non.
Tu ne vas pas voir un podologue quand tu as un problème de dents.
Bah voilà. Bah moi je fais du droit du travail, monsieur.
Moi je connais un podologue qui est très honorable
et qui peut te faire, je pense, une ou deux couronnes, peut-être un détartrage.
Tu as compris le problème !
Oui, j’ai compris que vous étiez une belle bande de branques, ça j’ai bien compris.
Bon bah, j’ai fait la collab avec Monté sur la communication optimale.
Je ne vais pas vous cacher, ce n’était pas vraiment très intéressant.
De toutes façons, je n’aime pas bosser avec lui.
Et puis je le trouve vraiment discourtois et rustique.
Moi, avec Monté ça va, j’ai pas trop de problème.
Je limite mes interactions avec lui, par contre.
Moi Monté, je l’aime beaucoup.
Il a été d’une grande aide pour moi après la mort de Shirley, il en parlait beaucoup.
Avec des mots qui étaient les siens, c’est sûr, mais ça partait du coeur j’en suis persuadée.
Depuis que la cousine de Valentine est morte,
on paye quand même 20 balles de moins d'électricité.
Moi j’ai envie de dire, un mal pour un bien.
Quoiqu’il en soit, James Cooke Brown prend un peu le melon,
il explique dans sa grammaire revisée du Loglan de 1989 que sa langue est un médicament efficace face à la maladie de la pensée limitée,
un moyen d’éveiller l’humanité et qu’elle devrait être enseignée aux enfants du monde entier…
un peu prétentieux le bonhomme.
Un peu.
A ce moment-là, une partie de l’équipe de James Cooke Brown l’a déjà lâché dans son délire et s’est déjà retiré du projet Loglan.
En 1987, ces séparatistes loglanistes ont créé une autre langue visant les mêmes buts que cette dernière :
la logique avant tout, la neutralité culturelle, la non-ambigüité des énoncés.
Et surtout, pas d’histoire de droits d’auteur ni de délire mégalomane.
C’est le Lojban, qui ne tarde pas à dépasser le Loglan en terme de contributeurs et d’impact.
Mais est-ce que c’est si optimal que ça, finalement ?
Eh bien… pas du tout.
Parce que si on peut analyser le Lojban comme un langage de programmation informatique, il est en réalité très peu pratique pour communiquer.
Les constructions, même pour les énoncés les plus élémentaires, sont très lourdes.
Le critère de non-ambigüité est un handicap plus qu’autre chose.
C’est bien beau d’avoir plein de façon différente de dire “et” ou “ou”,
en fonction du sens exact que l’on veut faire passer,
mais cette précision est dans un contexte de conversation quotidien très superflue,
le temps nécessaire que l’on met à former une phrase correcte,
dont on est sûr que le sens corresponde exactement à notre pensée,
est beaucoup trop long,
et le temps nécessaire pour comprendre une phrase l’est tout autant.
urtout que la langue relève au quotidien d’un acte essentiellement spontané
On n'est pas sorti du bois si on doit mettre 2mn pour réfléchir à chacune de ses phrases.
Bon okay, parler de manière non-ambigüe et culturellement neutre est un horizon inatteignable qui semble complexifier la communication plutôt que la rendre optimale pour nous humains.
Peut-être tout simplement parce que nos langues évoluent dans un contexte social et culturel qui aide bien plus qu’il ne dessert,
et qui apporte à nos langues naturelles des informations indispensables à l’oral.
Parce que le contexte est central. Vous pouvez dire
j’ai froid” pour faire comprendre “j’ai besoin que tu fermes la fenêtre s’il te plait, celle qui est derrière toi”.
“J’ai froid” véhicule alors beaucoup plus d’information que la simple idée que vous ayez froid,
et chercher à transposer cet énoncé hors de tout contexte nous fait en réalité perdre beaucoup d’informations.
Bon, t’as bien un truc à dire sur le contexte, avec je sais pas moi, la comm, la pub, LinkedIn.
J’en sais rien.
Bah, je n’ai pas vraiment grand chose non plus en fait.
Tu te fous de ma gueule ?
Ah bah j’ai quand même un peu… j’ai quelques trucs.
Bon ça va nous changer parce que…
Le contexte, oui, le contexte est important. Selon le lieu où on va communiquer ou même la période de l’année.
Si tu communiques à Noël, si tu communiques dans une école, dans la rue, etc.
Y a une prise de conscience, y a un contexte qui fait que le message va être interprété différemment.
La cible aussi, et tous ses référents, ça va influencer la manière dont on s’adresse à nous, les images qu’on va présenter, ce genre de choses.
Moi, j’ai un exemple de marque, tu vas me confirmer si c’est juste ou pas, de marque qui a fait de la communication optimale je trouve.
Je ne sais pas si tu vois la bière Gordon.
- Tu vois pas ?
- Non.
C’est une bière qui est assez forte, qui est assez chargée,
et du coup, elle se positionne pas mal là-dessus, sur le fait que c’est un peu un truc de bonhomme.
Si tu prends tout ce contexte là, le passé de la marque sachant qu’elle a déjà une certaine réputation qui est déjà bien assise, autour du fait qu’elle est forte.
Le fait qu’elle cible ces personnes-là et qu’elle s’intéresse qu’à ceux-là et qu’on doit tenir compte qu’on s’adresse qu’à des bonshommes, tu vois ?
Et bah, ça fait qu’ils ont fait une campagne où c’est juste la canette de bière sur des fonds très simple où il est écrit
“Rien à prouver”.
Et au final, en faisant ça, c’est intéressant,
tu communiques plein de choses sans rien communiquer.
Ouais, tout est le contexte là.
Tout est contingent de ce qui existe déjà.
La marque ne dit rien, mais en même temps, il y a un côté prétentieux un peu cool.
Genre la marque, elle père, elle est là, c’est un truc de bonhomme et tout, y a rien à prouver, y a rien à dire.
Pas de slogan, de truc pour faire rire. C’est le produit en lui même comme ça, sa réputation, la personne à laquelle il s’adresse et tout se crée autour de ça quoi.
Ça raconte un truc, sans rien dire.
Et bah, pour un mec qui n’avait rien à dire, tu en avais des trucs à dire.
C’est parce que je n’avais pas fait de petite présa, j’avais l’impression d’avoir mal travaillé, je suis désolé…
Pas mal. Tu m’as presque intéressé.
Merci, ça me fait plaisir. Une petite note ?
Non.
Pour autant, ne jetons pas le bébé avec l’eau du bain.
Si chasser l'ambiguïté n’est pas un bon plan, il n’empêche qu’on peut continuer à chasser l’irrégularité.
Pourquoi avoir autant de radicaux au verbe savoir par exemple ?
Savoir, je sais, qu’il sache, j’ai su, je saurai, que nous sussions…
On peut légitimement imaginer que plus de régularité, ça fait moins de modèles à assimiler.
Suffit de voir la difficulté que c’est pour nous d’apprendre le latin avec toutes ses déclinaisons,
pareil pour l’allemand ou le russe,
alors que l’anglais ou y’a ni masculin, ni féminin, ni déclinaisons… c’est vachement plus simple quand même.
C’est en tout cas quelque chose qu’on entend beaucoup.
Si on suit cette logique, une langue comme le mandarin, relativement régulière et dénuée de déclinaisons, serait plus optimale.
De plus, comme elle dispose de mots relativement courts, beaucoup de termes composés d’une seule syllabe, la vitesse de transmission de l’information doit être d’autant plus rapide.
Alors allons-nous tous devoir apprendre à parler comme les chinois ?
Rassurez-vous, ce n’est pas le cas.
Une étude conduite par des chercheurs du CNRS il y a quelques mois a montré que peu importe la langue que vous parlez,
vous communiquez la même quantité d’information par seconde, estimée à environ 39 bits, plus ou moins 5 bits.
Pour le calcul, me demandez pas comment ils ont fait,
vous irez directement voir l'étude en question, qui est en description.
Si effectivement le mandarin dispose de mots plus courts que l’espagnol par exemple,
et si donc chaque syllabe est en moyenne vectrice d’une plus grande quantité d’information,
le débit de parole d’un locuteur du mandarin est plus faible que celui d’un locuteur de l’espagnol.
Plus une langue véhicule d’information par syllabe, moins on la parle vite donc.
Comme s’il existait une limite technique à nos langues.
En tout cas ça fait du bien de pouvoir parler sans plomber l’ambiance.
Je sais que c’est parfois un peu lourd de discuter avec les autres du décès de ma cousine, de cette sordide histoire de météorite qui a conduit un homme à l’hôpital.
Ici, je peux vraiment aborder les choses.
Après, je suis pas sûr que ça dérange les autres mais bon…
Ah mais Valentine, c’est le malaise incarné.
Ah, si on votait pour éliminer les candidats comme à la belle époque de la télé-réalité sur les chaines nationales,
peut-être que Valentine aurait vécu un coup dur.
J’adore Valentine, mais faut qu’elle arrête de faire des blagues sur sa famille.
Surtout quand ils sont décédés.
Et surtout quand ils sont dissimulés illégalement dans le congélateur de la maison.
Ça l'aide peut-être à faire le deuil, mais moi, je n’arrive pas à oublier qui habite sous le sachet de frites.
Et vous, cher public, vous voteriez pour éliminer qui ?
Laisser un commentaire que je ne lirai pas.
Quand on conceptualise l’optimalité chez nous autres Européens, elle est focalisée sur la morphologie,
c’est-à-dire sur la forme des mots.
En revanche, elle ne concerne jamais ou rarement la syntaxe, c’est-à-dire l’ordre des mots,
ni la phonologie, c’est-à-dire les sons qu’utilisent une langue.
Alors certes l’anglais est une langue considérée facile grammaticalement, c’est-à-dire sur sa morphologie,
quoiqu’on pourrait débattre sur ce point précis,
mais c’est une langue à la syntaxe rigide,
c’est à dire à l’ordre des mots très très rigide.
C’est en réalité tout à fait logique.
Sans cas grammaticaux, c’est-à-dire sans déclinaison des mots comme en latin, en allemand ou en russe,
l’information grammaticale n’est pas portée sur les mots mais sur la phrase,
l’ordre des mots notamment.
En allemand, si on peut indifféremment dire Den Mann seht die Frau ou die Frau seht den Mann sans que le sens global ne change,
car les déclinaisons identifient qui fait et qui subit l’action,
ce n’est absolument pas possible en français ni en anglais, car en l’absence de cas grammaticaux,
en l’absence de déclinaisons,
c’est l’ordre des mots qui détermine qui subit
ou qui fait l’action.
L’homme voit la femme ou la femme voit l’homme conduisent à des résultats très différents.
Des résultats opposés, même.
Comme vous parlez français, cela vous paraît naturel et certainement logique.
Sachez cependant que cet ordre des mots n’est pas majoritaire dans le monde.
Cet ordre sujet-verbe-objet est présent dans 42% des langues,
45% d’entre elles préfèrent par contre l’ordre sujet-objet-verbe,
qui est la disposition la plus courante, que l’on trouve en japonais,
en basque, en hindi ou en coréen par exemple.
Suivre l’ordre Sujet-Verbe-Objet que l’on trouve en français ou en anglais, ce n’est pas naturel ni optimal,
et c’est même une sacré contrainte lorsque l’on parle à l’origine une langue qui propose un ordre des mots beaucoup plus libre.
On pourrait aussi aller voir du côté de la phonologie.
L’anglais, encore une fois, possède en réalité une phonologie très complexe,
avec 12 voyelles et des diphtongues, c’est-à-dire des combinaisons de deux voyelles,
là aussi assez nombreuses.
On a de nombreuses consonnes distinguées qui ne le sont pas dans plein de langues,
comme le [r] et le [l] qui sont confondus en mandarin ou en japonais.
On pourrait parler aussi de l’accentuation des mots qui en anglais est bien souvent imprévisible et absolument pas régulière,
bien qu’elle soit parfois distinctive :
le mot import est un nom s’il est accentué sur la première syllabe,
mais un verbe s’il est accentué sur la seconde syllabe.
Et lorsque la syllabe d’un mot en anglais est inaccentuée,
le timbre de la voyelle change souvent de sorte à obtenir un schwa, c’est-à-dire une voyelle neutre.
L’optimalité donc, telle qu’on la perçoit et telle qu’on l’a définie historiquement en Europe, est très ethnocentrée.
D’autant plus que nous parlons en Europe des langues qui empruntent des chemins évolutifs similaires, ayant pour origine une même langue, le Proto-Indo-Européen
qui était parlé dans les steppes ukrainiennes il y a 6 ou 8000 ans.
Mais revenons sur l’irrégularité.
Comment justifier son existence, n’est-ce pas superflu quoiqu’il arrive ?
Si vous avez suivi ce que j’ai dit, l’irrégularité ne doit jamais être perçue comme uniquement portée sur la morphologie, sur la forme des mots.
Il est parfois plus efficace de justement troquer la régularité d’un modèle morphologique pour faciliter la prononciation d’un mot, par exemple.
Il existe même en phonétique une loi appelée “la loi du relâchement articulatoire”,
tendance de fond de certaines évolutions, et à l’origine de plusieurs mutations phonétiques courantes.
Parce que vous ne vous en rendez pas compte, mais les langues évoluent.
Le français y compris.
Certes, cela évolue lentement, si bien que nous ne vous en rendez pas compte la plupart du temps,
mais ça évolue quand même.
Et lorsqu’une langue évolue, elle se met déjà en quête de l’optimalité.
On invente les mots dont on a besoin tout en éliminant ceux qui n’existent plus dans l’usage.
on emprunte ce qui nous manque,
si une forme irrégulière est trop peu utilisée elle est alors abandonnée ou modifiée pour rentrer dans un modèle plus courant et plus simple.
Un mot irrégulier se maintient en revanche très bien s’il est très utilisé, comme le verbe être et ses formes conjuguées par exemple.
Les irrégularités d‘aujourd’hui doivent être perçues comme des évolutions passées de la langue ou des vestiges des systèmes anciens.
Si le verbe être est aussi irrégulier lorsqu’on le conjugue au présent,
c’est parce que chaque forme a subi une évolution phonologique à travers les siècles qui ont conduit à ce résultat,
et cette pression à l’évolution phonologique était bien plus forte que la pression du maintien de la régularité.
Et faut avouer qu’elles sont bien pratiques.
De même, la forme populaire “chu” ou “chui”,
contraction de “je” et “suis” est hautement irrégulière au regard des autres verbes
mais est à la fois très courte, bien comprise et largement identifiable.
Comme le son [ʒ] et [s] sont très proches dans la bouche et difficile à prononcer l’un après l’autre,
la forme “chu” est plus optimale,
le son [ʃ] ayant le même point et le même mode d’articulation que le son [ʒ], mais dévoisé,
c’est-à-dire prononcé sans l’intervention des cordes vocales, comme le son [s].
Par ailleurs, l’irrégularité est parfois l’étape nécessaire entre deux systèmes qui eux sont tout à fait réguliers.
Par exemple, le mot bail fait son pluriel en baux historiquement
et c’est encore le cas dans le secteur de l’immobilier.
Le mot bail dans le sens “histoire, rumeur, ragot”, ayant fait surface ces dernières années,
fait quant à lui son pluriel de manière régulière : un bail, des bails.
Tu connais les bails.
A première vue, on pourrait percevoir ici une irrégularité, un défaut d’optimalité, mais il faut plutôt le voir ainsi :
le pluriel en -aux des mots en -al ou -ail est en train de disparaître,
beaucoup de mots empruntés au cours des dernières siècles forment d’ailleurs leur pluriel régulièrement, comme carnaval ou chacal.
Bail en tant que nouveau mot est régulier, il se distingue du mot bail en tant qu’ancien mot,
vestige d’un système qui aura bientôt cessé d’exister.
C’est une évolution en cours,
qui suit son cours.
L’évolution de nos rapports me laisse pantoise, j’avoue.
Je me demande si c’était pareil avec les anciens locataires.
Après moi ça va ma situation, elle est confortable, étant donné qu’ils sont pas vachement moins malins que moi.
Je me demande bien comment ça va finir.
Mais comment peut-on prédire une évolution dans la langue, d’ailleurs ?
On ne le peut jamais avec certitude, mais on peut observer que s’il restera peut-être toujours des archaïsmes,
les langues évoluent en suivant une tendance de fond.
C’est ce qu’on appelle le cycle de grammaticalisation.
Mais par définition, ce cycle est un modèle très lent et très généraliste, qui s’applique plus ou moins en fonction des cas que l’on étudie.
Ce cycle, on peut le schématiser ainsi :
prenons une langue qui serait constituée de paradigmes organisés,
bien réguliers, bien optimale finalement selon les penseurs cités en début de cet épisode.
Avec le temps,
si ce n’est pas déjà le cas, les affixes, comme les prépositions, se colleraient aux mots.
On verrait alors apparaître ce qu’on appelle des cas grammaticaux, c’est-à-dire ce qu’on appelle couramment des déclinaisons.
Appelons cela le stade 1.
Avec le temps, les mutations phonétiques, comme la loi du relâchement articulatoire, dont on a déjà parlé,
pourraient alléger la difficulté de prononciation de certaines formes,
cela pourrait réduire la taille des mots,
et c’est sans parler des diverses mutations qui de toute façon apparaissent avec le temps.
De fait, des irrégularités apparaissent dans les paradigmes,
c’est-à-dire dans les modèles de déclinaison,
le système régulier devient irrégulier,
les modèles deviennent parfois opaques.
Le temps passant encore, les déclinaisons finiraient par disparaître,
tout comme les flexions.
Les marques de conjugaison aussi, les marques du pluriel aussi. C'est le stade 3.
Le stade 4, c’est lorsque qu’apparaissent des constructions syntaxiques pour remplacer les déclinaisons disparues.
La construction de la phrase porte désormais l’information grammaticale nécessaire à la compréhension d’un énoncé.
On voit alors des nouveaux temps apparaître par exemple,
construit avec des auxiliaires,
les déterminants deviennent obligatoires car ils servent désormais à indiquer le genre ou le nombre du mot qu’ils déterminent.
Au stade 5, toutes ces nouvelles structures se rigidifient et se figent puis au stade 6,
on analyse ces déterminants ou ces prépositions comme des affixes,
c’est-à-dire comme des marques directement liées aux mots.
Nous sommes en réalité retournés au premier stade.
Le français, actuellement, est dans le stade 4,
le proto-gallo-roman parlé durant le début du moyen-âge en était au stade 3,
le latin au stade 2 et le proto-indo-européen probablement au stade 1.
Ce qui nous paraît optimal,
ce sur quoi ont beaucoup écrit les philosophes au cours des derniers siècles,
si on regarde bien, c’est ce vers quoi on tend actuellement.
Le stade 5 ou 6.
Des structures régulières, un ordre des mots plus que jamais déterminant.
Bref, l’optimalité est ce vers quoi la langue tend d'elle-même avec l’inertie qui est la sienne.
Finalement, chercher la langue la plus optimale qui soit…
c’est une entreprise qui semble vaine.
Nos langues actuelles, aussi imparfaites soient-elles, cherchent en permanence à s’adapter et à coller à la société dans laquelle on vit.
Elles s’appuient pour cela sur le contexte donc, qui est à la fois extérieur à nous mais aussi intérieur, c’est-à-dire tributaire de notre biologie.
Nos langues sont aussi ce qu’elles sont car notre corps est ce qu’il est et nos organes sont ce qu’ils sont.
Nous avons vu précédemment que décontextualiser une langue n’est pas efficace du tout.
S’affranchir de notre culture, de notre société, de notre corps et éviter l'ambiguïté peut sembler plus universel
et donc moins susceptible de créer des problèmes de compréhension,
mais en tendant vers un fonctionnement plus logique,
au sens informatique ou mathématique du terme,
nous extrayons la langue de son fonctionnement habituel
et nous créons finalement bien plus de problèmes de communication
que l’on en évite.
Cela peut sembler contrintuitif,
mais exploiter le contexte est certainement plus optimal.
La langue est un produit social, il ne faut jamais l’oublier.
Idem pour l’irrégularité, en nous obstinant à ne voir que celles qui portent sur la morphologie, on oublie de voir les autres,
et en quoi elles peuvent en réalité être la conséquence de simplifications conduisant à plus d’optimalité.
Tel mot est peut-être irrégulier en forme,
mais peut-être que cette irrégularité est venu corriger une difficulté à le prononcer.
En latin par exemple, le suffixe -alis se transforme en -aris après un /l/ pour éviter la prononcer deux l de suite.
Singuli > singularis,
mais plures > pluralis.
En français, singulier et pluriel n’ont pas la même terminaison mais ils sont originellement construit sur le même modèle,
avec le même suffixe latin,
qui a été altéré pour faciliter la prononciation.
D’ailleurs, une langue comme l’espéranto, créée au début du 20e siècle et basée sur la régularité stricte,
expérimente aujourd’hui après un siècle d’existence
quelques évolutions naturelles qui viennent mettre à mal sa régularité parfaite.
Certains mots ont changé de prononciation en cours de route pour être plus facile à prononcer, comme ĥemio qui existe aussi sous la forme kemio,
certaines formes comme celles du verbe être sont régulièrement abrégées,
comme estas en stas, la syntaxe théoriquement libre est dans les faits de plus en plus rigide.
Mais je trouve, à titre personnel, qu’on se prend trop la tête sur ces questions d’optimalité.
Car le français, par exemple, est tout à fait équipé pour être à la fois très précis dans certains cas, et beaucoup moins quand cela n’est pas de circonstance.
C’est ce qu’on appelle les jargons en fait.
Chaque milieu qui nécessite d’être précis dans son domaine en fait usage, et c’est souvent des termes longs et pas ambigus du tout.
D’ailleurs, ils ne sont souvent pas dans le dictionnaire que vous avez dans votre bibliothèque, il risquerait sinon de tripler de volume.
Imaginez s’il fallait tous les maîtriser,
tous les jargons de tous les milieux !
On pourrait parler très précisément entre nous, c’est sûr.
Mais dans les faits, on utiliserait jamais la majeure partie des mots mémorisés et cela sera de l’espace inutilement occupé.
Ce serait loin d’être optimal.
Alors peut-être que le mot hystérocinétique est super pratique en linguistique historique pour l’étude de la reconstruction du proto-indo-européen,
et qu’il m’a été utile à l’université,
mais pour vous il est certainement superflu.
Un accent hystérocinétique, c’est un accent
qui passe du suffixe à la terminaison quand il est décliné dans les cas faibles,
comme dans le mot *ph₂-tér-m̥.
Alors, vous êtes pas super avancés car il faudrait définir en linguistique à quoi correspond un suffixe, une terminaison, un cas faible, et tous les symboles utilisés dans le mot affiché à l’écran.
La flemme un peu du coup.
Vraiment.
L’optimalité, c’est donc certainement la situation actuelle.
Chaque milieu maitrise son jargon, et même si cela concerne une minorité,
celle qui en a besoin, cela suffit.
Lorsque le plus grand nombre doit y avoir accès, la vulgarisation est là pour nous faire comprendre,
rendre accessible, ces phrases jargonnées.
Et c’est bien comme ça.
Voilà, si cet épisode vous a plu, vous pouvez liker,  commenter, partager et vous abonner, faire péter le compteur de vue,
faire monter la vidéo en tendance et surtout nous rejoindre sur Discord,
ce soir ou d’autres jours, pour notamment débriefer de tout cela.
Bon, j’ai dérushé vos interventions dans le confessionnal.
Attend on était filmé ?
Attend quoi?
Mais ça se fait pas de filmer les gens à leur insu…
Ho Valentine molo, c’est pas ça comme ça que tu vas convaincre les gens de te garder,
et puis Florence, je serais toi, je la ramènerais pas trop, vu ce que tu balances sur moi.
Oui, vous étiez filmé, qu’est-ce que vous aviez cru ?
Mais regardez, parce que ça devrait vous intéresser quand même.
À un moment j’ai cru que Florence allait comprendre, mais ils sont tous tombés dans le panneau.
Confondre un œuf de Yoni et une météorite… même Valentine est tombée dans le panneau.
Comment ils ont pu gober ça…
Nan, mais, je peux tout expliquer.
Attend, quoi?!
Un œuf de Yoni ?
Les trucs qu’on se met dans la tulipe ?
Mais tu foutais quoi avec ça ?
Et tu m’as laissé faire un épisode là-dessus,
et tu l’as vendu à un mec, et maintenant il est à l’hôpital !
Mais non, c’est à ta cousine Shirley, celle qui est morte.
Tu crois que c’est pas plus grave ça que de s’occuper de ça comme ça ?
Moi à la base,
je voulais juste la couvrir pour son œuf de machin.
En fait, vous me reprochez d’être gentil.
Oh mon Dieu,
il est gentil.
Je suis vraiment désolé d’avoir voulu être fidèle.
Mais c’est quoi cette défense ?
T’as pas honte quand même !
C’est ça.
Lâchez tout.
Déstressez un bon coup. Qu’on puisse passer à autre chose.
Oui, c'est qui ? C'est moi.
Moi actuellement depuis Touiche.
Depuis Touiche pour vous dire que vous pouvez venir pour en parler.
Pour parler de ce sujet, c'est pas beau, c'est pas magnifique ça ?
Donc, venez.
Venez, finalement, venez en parler dans le chat.
Venez discuter de tout ça,
livrer vos réflexions poussées et intenses.
Et c'est déjà pas mal.
N'est-ce pas ?